racolage beaucoup plus discret les sites
se multiplient depuis deux ou trois ans
en quête frédéric protat patrick voix en
plein centre ville
une entreprise qui ne connaît pas la
crise une quinzaine de salariés certains
en contrat à durée indéterminée le
studio n'a rien d'hollywoodien le fonds
de commerce ici c'est le x1 ambroisie un
endroit canapé plus salon en fait les
actrices peut faire leur intervention en
direct soit chez elle soit des studios à
sedan les prévenir des actrices de vente
une caméra des milliers de connexions
chaque jour ici l'internaute peut tout
trouver de la vidéo coquine à la porno
réalité on atteint les 80 mille euros
par mois de chiffre d'affaires en
abonnement on pense qu'on va le doublé
dans les deux ans à venir où on est dans
une mode de téléchargement de deux films
bien précis qui sont demandées choses
qui sont plus compliquées à obtenir en
allant dans un sex-shop ou dans un
magasin spécialisé
ça facilite le business effectivement
mais en même temps il faut être très
prudent car pour un site en règle avec
la loi combien d'autres qui servent de
façade à des réseaux de proxénétisme
ce site propose par exemple des rendez
vous avec des actrices de films pornos
cet autre est basé onglet lorsqu'on le
contact voici ce qui vous est proposé
enfin on a dû fuir la paris yasmina pour
les proxénètes qui exploitent ces sites
c'est un moyen d'échapper aux loi sur le
racolage de plus en plus à une
prostitution qui que je fais qui est
plus volatile entre guillemets c'est à
dire que les moins visibles par les
riverains mais qu'elle est offerte tout
un chacun sur internet qu'on a
maintenant plus en plus de jeunes femmes
qui ne se constituent plus physiquement
mais distribue de cartes
avec affichage des tarifs photos et
mensurations puisque vous voulez pour
lutter contre ces réseaux une seule arme
une coopération internationale entre la
france et des pays où ces sites sont
fabriqués hébergés et parfois protégés